was super bowl week in houston and when
the reports first came out we were like
what
john lynch going to become a general
manager and the first thought was this
could either be john elway or matt
millen and so far it's closer to elway
the good old way always had some good
and some bad in his nine years with the
broncos but it really has turned around
in year three for john lynch and it
wasn't that long ago that there was talk
about how lynch and shanahan maybe it's
not going to work and they had the 4 and
12 season last year and maybe the heat's
going to be on one or both of them this
year notwithstanding the six-year
contracts fully guaranteed that both
have but it really has worked out and it
always takes time everybody wants that
quick fix in the nfl especially when you
see a team like the 49ers turn around
from four and 12 one year to super bowl
the next but it does take time to get
the players in place to run the offense
and the defense that kyle shanahan
envisioned and john lynch did a hell of
a job finding the right players to run
that team the way shanahan wants it
sometimes he ask a question when you're
talking to somebody and you really don't
know what direction he's going to go
uh and i did not know that story
and i said to myself that's that's an
incredible story and how about when he
says you know i basically didn't sleep
for like the next four nights
um
and
one of the reasons why i think john
lynch
is really really good at this job
and again why
we could get in a long argument it'd be
a fun podcast one day for me and you to
do
but
i happen to think that what ruined matt
millen
in detroit
was
and we could argue about this a long
time he was basically forced to pick
joey harrington he didn't want to pick
joey harrington but in retrospect now
what has been the absolute key for the
49ers the key is getting the quarterback
who can win games when your team is not
playing great
getting a quarterback who can overcome
some obstacles that's what jimmy
garoppolo has done this year and so to
me
every general manager who works why is
john elway getting such a grace period
in denver
because he convinced peyton manning
eight years ago along with pat bolan who
was in declining health but he also
helped he convinced peyton manning to go
to denver
and he got a super bowl out of it as it
turns out
but in my opinion it's all about the
quarterback however that happened and
one day it's either going to be in the
john lynch book or the bill belichick
book
how jimmy garoppolo landed in san
francisco for a two
you know because he could have gotten
more elsewhere but that has been the
whole key getting a quarterback somehow
some way lynch and shanahan got that
done and that to me has made all the
difference
but it's amazing that in the playoffs
jimmy garoppolo has essentially become
bob greasy right throwing the ball eight
times in the nfc championship game and
who knows how many times he'll throw the
ball against the chiefs in the super
bowl peter i think one of the keys here
and to the extent that there is anything
about the 49ers that other teams can
copy
i think the 49ers with shanahan and
lynch have done a great job of finding
guys who are natural born roughnecks who
don't need the reps that no longer are
available in hitting and blocking and
tackling to the ground football has gone
dramatically in the direction away from
full contact at practices they're trying
to eliminate concussions you do that in
part by having practices not nearly as
intense as they used to be so what
happens what happens is you get to a
game and patrick holmes is running to
the end zone and nobody knows how to
tackle him i think the 49ers have found
guys on the offensive and defensive side
of the ball who don't need that they are
natural born badasses who will go out
there and execute without hesitation
without practice reps they just know
how to overpower you like a george
kittle he's the epitome of it the
defense is the same way but especially
with that running game why all of a
sudden are the 49ers cracking the code
on the running game because defenses
don't know how to tackle anymore and
they don't know how to fight off the
blocks anymore because they don't do it
full speed like they used to they found
guys who don't need to do it full speed
in practice i think that's been the very
subtle key to this and that's the
challenge for other teams find guys like
that who can match that brawn match that
will match that violence in games
against the 49ers
mike there's one other guy who we don't
talk about with the san francisco 49ers
who absolutely unequivocally we should
one day he will be a general manager in
the nfl his name is adam peters and he's
their personnel guy their chief college
guy
and i remember i was in the draft room
in night in 2017 before their first nfl
draft uh as a as a team you know lynch
and shanahan and adam peters sitting
over to one side
and they did something in the fifth
round of that draft and they took george
kittle that was by far
the best pick in terms of value in three
years that they've run this team and the
reason that they were able to get george
kittle in the fifth round is very simple
he was a devalued player at iowa the
coaching staff didn't really love him he
hadn't produced a lot
uh
and and i think he came to the nfl
as a real you know on the come guy and
the 49ers saw how much he loved football
and how much they thought he could
project to this level and that's exactly
what they've done
so a don't forget adam peters when we
talk about shanahan and lynch and b the
other part that i think is really
really important it isn't just getting
the nick bosas and and all those guys
even though they've spent huge draft
capital on the front when you spend huge
draft capital on the front you're gonna
have to find
fred warner george kittle later in the
draft you're gonna have to find raheem
mostert on the undrafted free agent
scrap heap after he's been cut by 64
teams that is what the 49ers have done
exceedingly well
and really the guy who's responsible
most directly and clearly for the 49ers
being in the super bowl i mean plenty of
guys have their hand in it but dre
greenlaw
not fading to his left
but crashing back to the right to get to
jacob hollister and keep him out of the
end zone because peter if hollister
scores that touchdown at the closing
moment of week 17 and the seahawks beat
the 49ers the 49ers are the five seed
and look maybe they would have won on
the road in philly they probably would
have like seattle did but then you gotta
go maybe to uh green bay and beat the 49
or beat the packers rather at lambeau
field or maybe have to go back to
seattle at some point i mean it's a far
different road and you don't get your
bye week that i think they desperately
needed and greenlaw doesn't make that
play we may be talking about the
seahawks or the packers or somebody else
in super bowl 54 not the san francisco
49ers
hey there's no question about it and
mike i i do think
sometimes when i think of the nfl's
playoff system and i think how
absolutely close that is how painfully
close that was for the seattle seahawks
because obviously if their home
you know for the first
week or to if they have a buy and then
they're home for either one or two weeks
how much of a huge difference this could
have
would have made in the nfc playoffs and
maybe
who makes it to the super bowl from the
nfc the one thing about
all of this
and i on one hand i think it's
tremendously unfair but on the other
hand
that's what makes a game like this that
we're showing right now a play like that
so incredibly spectacular
because
a play like that three inches can make
the difference in whether you win a
super bowl and that's not being overly
dramatic it's absolutely true
same thing for the chiefs though if the
patriots don't
fail to beat the dolphins in week 17 how
different that would have configured the
afc field and the chiefs would have been
the three seed and they wouldn't have
had a buy they would have had to face
the titans right out of the gates who
knows how it would have gone as a wild
card match up and then their reward
would have been they go to new england
for the divisional round and they're on
the road for potentially the afc
championship game in baltimore if they
had been able to hold serve uh et cetera
et cetera so uh it did really you know
when it comes down to that last couple
of weeks of the season to determine the
playoff tree we know most of the playoff
teams but those spots at the top of the
playoff tree we're reminded again and
again peter how critical they are you
also talk to joe staley after the nfc
championship game he is a link back to
the super bowl 47 49ers team uh
how confident was he after everything
that the 49ers have gone through since
super bowl 47 that he was ever going to
see another super bowl
i asked him flat out did you ever think
he'd be back here right now and he said
no i didn't
but he said the first time i sat and
listened to kyle shanahan i said hey
this guy is really really good we could
get back there and so i think that is
when
a coach can make all the difference and
look joe staley has been relatively
unscathed injury-wise in his career i'm
sure he's thinking hey
i make i don't even know what he makes
10 12 million whatever he makes
i'll make 30 million for the next three
years 35 million and i'll just sort of
slip into retirement and i will have had
a really good career uh you know played
in the super bowl and all that
but i think that kyle shanahan woke the
echoes in san francisco there's no doubt
about it and mike
i can't help but thinking
just think now if you're john elway
watching that game the other night
and you think about the coaching
decision that you had in front of you in
2017
and you ask yourself
i had kyle shanahan in the final two
did i really make the call that i made
because i think john elway will always
say going into the 2017 coach process he
had his mind made up that's one of the
things that he did differently with vic
fangio i'm going in with an open mind
i have no preconceived notions and in
2019 he made a better decision i think a
smarter decision than he made in 2017.
to take it back to where we started
though who's to say that kyle shanahan
and john elway would have formed that
working relationship that shanahan and
lynch have put together and it's worked
out perfectly and remember at the time
the thinking was shanahan was going to
have a hard time finding a gm
who is currently working for another
team because shanahan's running the show
and you can't
make that higher of a guy unless you're
giving him the full gm powers and
authorities and that's what made lynch a
perfect alternative and it was amazing
and i still remember how that just was
out of the blue and it was one of those
things where at first you say this makes
no sense but the more you thought about
it well i could see this making sense
and here we are three years later super
bowl 54 shanahan and lynch and the 49ers
back uh trying to win it for the first
time in 25 years
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports